the lab is sort of organized chaos there
are about 35 or 40 people in it graduate
students postdoctoral fellows
technicians support staff etc we have
probably an unusually broad research
program we focus in three major areas
work on the biology of small RNAs we
work on cancer biology usually with
focalin roles of small RNAs and cancer
and and ways in which we can use smaller
knees as a tool to understand cancer and
then we have sort of a 30-hour area
which is technology development and
genomics and mostly making use of some
new generation sequencing technologies
to try to understand everything from the
evolution of cancer to human evolution
well aren't RNA interference actually
now describes a fairly broad range of
biological phenomena the notion is that
RNA has a sequence just like DNA does
and that sequence can be used to
recognize complimentary RNAs that share
sort of the inverse of that sequence the
mirror image of that sequence if you
want to think about it that way and
through that recognition a lot of jobs
can be done the RNAs are recognized can
be destroyed they can be taken to
different places in the cell or they can
even guide processes as strange as
taking pieces out of the genome
depending on order what organism you're
talking about
so one of the evolutionarily deepest
rooted roles of RNAi is as a genome
defense it's a way that plants for
example recognize and fight viruses it's
a way that animals recognize parasitic
pieces of DNA within their own genomes
called transposons and shut those off
it's also a way that the cell uses RNA
to program the regulation of its own
genes and we can exploit any one of
these responses essentially tricking the
RNAi machinery into silencing any gene
that we want just by fooling the
machinery into recognizing it as the in
essence one of these foreign elements
and we can use that for a number of
purposes the one that we mainly use it
for is for trying to understand the
biology of those genes and again in our
case mostly trying to understand what
different sets of genes do in tumor
development
well we've done a number of experiments
in mice to try to figure out really what
rnai dozen in animals and I can give you
a couple of examples so one is we've
looked at the small RNAs that the cell
makes in order to regulate its own genes
and compared the spectrum of those small
RNAs in normal cells versus tumor cells
in one of the first cases that we did
this was in a tumor type called b-cell
lymphoma and by making that comparison
we discovered that there were a set of
micro RNAs which what these endogenous
small RNAs are called the differed
between the normal cells in the tumor
cells and turns out that that the the
locus of the gene which encodes those
micrornas is often amplified in that
specific tumor type and if we reproduce
that event adding extra copies of those
micro RNA genes we actually accelerate
the development of that particular tumor
in mice the other way that we approach
this problem is by taking all of the
components of the RNAi machinery all the
proteins that actually bind to the set
of small RNAs and the smaller neighs
program to do these regulatory events
and delete them from the genome and
essentially ask what the consequences
are and it was in part those experiments
that led us to the realization that rnai
in animals plays this sort of genome
defensive role protecting the DNA of
germ cells from the ravages of these
mobile genetic elements called
transposons
well for
a long time we've been interested in
using RNAi as a tool to silence genes of
interest whatever genes we want and in
fact my lab has built large collections
of RNAi inducing agents in fact
collections that could be used to turn
off every gene in the human and mouse
genome now the way that we use these to
investigate cancer biology is
essentially to take a set of cancer
cells Engineers engineer them so that
each cell has a different gene turned
off and then we ask how those cells
react under stress what genes do cancer
cells require that normal cells down
these are potential targets for therapy
what genes modify the response of cancer
cells to chemotherapeutic agents or
targeted therapies what genes modify the
ability of cancer cells to engraft and a
host to metastasize etc
well there are really two ways that the
one would move from the work that we're
doing into something that would be
applicable in the clinic one is a
process that's being repeated in many
pharmaceutical companies many labs
really built on the foundation of
understanding this basic piece of
biology which is searching for unique
vulnerabilities in tumor cells now once
one finds a cell upon which a particular
subtype of breast cancer for example
depends that the normal normal normal
mammary epithelial cells don't depend on
then one can find targeted agents
standard pharmacy using standard
pharmaceutical chemistry that could
inhibit the activity of that particular
target and there you would have a
potentially selective therapy in the way
that things like gleevec are selective
for specific gene rearrangement upon
which the tumor cells carrying that
rearrangement uniquely depend another
promise of RNAi is that it can be used
as a therapy itself and there is a
tremendous interest in this both in the
academic and industrial communities the
notion that pharmaceutical chemistry can
only access about twenty percent of the
the genes encoded in the genome because
we have a limited ability to regulate
chemically the activity of the proteins
encoded by the other eighty percent RNAi
doesn't have such a limitation all it
needs to be able to do is to
specifically recognize the the sequence
of that gene in order to shut it off and
so it is essentially in some ways a
potentially Universal pharmaceutical
approach the difficulty is and I think
this is where many of us are focusing a
lot of effort is trying to figure out
how to take this relatively large
molecule compared to a normal
pharmaceutical and get it efficiently
delivered to the cells in which the
therapy needs to operate and so really
that is one of the major barriers to
taking this basic science discovery and
really exploiting it
as a tool for improving human health
well I think that the way this barrier
to delivery will be overcome is is
chemistry so I it's clear that we've
pushed the biology of RNAi as a
silencing tool sufficiently far that
given an ability to live to deliver this
we could shut off any gene that that we
wanted to in fact we could probably dial
the activity of these inhibitors to the
point that we could even figure out
exactly how far down we have to turn a
gene maybe you don't want to shut it off
because maybe it's essential maybe what
you want to inhibit its activity fifty
percent or eighty percent and the tools
are understanding the biology is
sufficient that we can achieve that with
the tools that we have I think that
where we'll see advances in delivery
come from is in changing the chemistry
of the small RNA itself sufficiently
that it can pass through cell membranes
without the aid of a specific delivery
agent delivery agents are the other sort
of arm of research into rnai delivery
encapsulating RNAs and lipids in
polymers and that's another strategy for
getting smaller neighs into cells but my
own feeling is that the unform elated
molecules probably have the best
potential to be a future therapy it's a
simpler formulation then something that
we know where you're mixing an RNA agent
and a series for example of polymers to
try to get them across the cell
but this is I think an interesting story
about the social aspects of science in a
way the the realization that this
transmissible cancer even existed came
from a graduate student in my lab who
I'm happened to be Tasmanian she did her
PhD on sort of basic aspects of RNAi
biology and when she finished her degree
before she moved on to a position as a
postdoctoral fellow she was looking for
a transition project and she explained
to me that this transmissible cancer
existed that in the last 10 years it had
wiped out roughly half of the devil
population and that it was estimated to
actually drive the devils to extinction
sometime within the next 30 or so years
if nothing were to be done so she was
very passionate about this and convinced
me that we had the tools to try to
understand at least something about the
biology of this disease now there are
only two transmissible cancers that I
but I know about where the cancer itself
the cancer cells themselves move from
one individual to another there's the
this Tasmanian devil facial tumour and
there's also a tumor that does this in
dogs in dogs the the tumor isn't as
aggressive it often spontaneously goes
into remission and doesn't often kill
the animals that are in essence infected
with this in Tasmanian devils the tumor
is extremely aggressive often kills
affected animals in roughly six months
with these horrific facial tumors that
ultimately kill the animal often because
they grow so large that the animal can
no longer eat but it's a very aggressive
disease also in the sense that it
metastasizes too many sites in the body
but the the the animals are killed so
quickly that it's usually not the
metastasis that caused them to succumb
as happens in in many instances of human
cancer so our basic question was really
to try to understand the origins of this
transmissible tumor
try to understand what cell type the
tumor is derived from so that we could
maybe gain some insight into why this
tumor has such an unusual etiology and
also to try to understand why it is that
this tumor can spread from individual to
individual you know is that such an
unusual property we came at it from a
number of different perspectives first
really founded upon our work in small
RNA so each cell type expresses a
specific repertoire of small RNAs that
it uses to regulate genes but that
repertoire is also kind of a signature
of the cell type that the des small RNAs
are expressed in so you can use a small
earn a signature to tell a mammary cell
from a germ cell you can tell a nerve
cell from a muscle cell and so we
started off by asking what spectrum of
small RNAs these devil facial tumour
zeeeee expressed and that pointed us in
addition to looking at the messenger
RNAs the RNAs that encode proteins
within that cell by looking at the
smaller nee profiles and the messenger
RNA profiles that really led us to a
specific cell type which in this case
happens to be a schwann cell now what
schwann cells are is essentially like
the insulation on a wire they wrap nerve
cells and act it essentially as an
insulator to to make their conductance
of signals more efficient
well i mean i think that the two things
that really come out of the work that
we've done looking both of the tumor and
at the host animals are that the host
animals themselves are remarkably
genetically homogeneous and so one I
think insight that emerged from the
study was that the notion that the
tumors may be able to spread from animal
to animal you know essentially like a
metastasis but within a population
rather than within an organism in part
because the animals can't recognize
these cells as foreign now in terms of a
treatment it's difficult to envision
wild animals undergoing cancer therapy
you can't really imagine a mobile I see
you in the Tasmanian bush but but one
thing that that one can consider is a
prophylactic therapy and so cancer
vaccines have kind of a bad rap in part
because they haven't worked particularly
well for humans but the the unusual
nature of the Tasmanian devil tumor the
fact that every tumor is identical is a
very different situation than one was
has with human cancers where every
cancer is is different is individual not
only to the person but in its genetic
composition and so in some cases the
difficulties of developing cancer
vaccines in humans might be related to
the heterogeneity of tumors whereas when
is precisely the opposite situation in
Tasmanian devils so one can really
envision two approaches one is the
approach that's being taken which is to
take it to take a set of devils and set
them aside as an insurance population
and so you essentially sequester
disease-free devils with the idea that
you know should the population actually
go extinct in the wild you have animals
to reintroduce now in that case we can
use the work that we've done which in
essence led to a diagnostic marker for
this disease to ensure that you know any
tumors that that insurance population
might develop aren't
d FTD in this second instance one date
imagine trying to develop a vaccine
against this particular unusual tumor
cell that could potentially be used on
wild populations although again you can
imagine the challenges that that one
would face in doing that
well so although each cancer is unique
there are certain core pathways
biological modules in essence that are
altered in nearly every cancer cell and
the number of those modules expands as
one gets more specific to our particular
subtype let's say estrogen
receptor-positive breast cancer so the
notion and this is one of the ways in
which i think RNAi is being deployed
very powerfully is to try to correlate
the vulnerabilities that are created by
the inactivation of those individual
biological modules and then exploit that
vulnerability for therapy the way that
you can think about this is that cells
are designed or evolved to be robust and
every time you take away one of these
these biological modules these pathways
it affects the robustness of cells think
about a Jenga tower and you're pulling
blocks out of the Jenga tower the more
blocks that you pull out the easier it
is to make that tower fall and what
people are doing with RNAi is is trying
to figure out precisely what additional
block to pull out to make that tower
fall where the tower wouldn't fall if
one had a normal cell which essentially
has homeostatic mechanisms to be robust
to resist the biological difficulties
that would be created by the loss of the
pathway that would represent that key
therapeutic target and so the idea is to
exploit common aspects of the genetics
to create therapies that that overcome
the individuality of the disease
well so although each cancer is unique
there are certain core pathways
biological modules in essence that are
altered in nearly every cancer cell and
the number of those modules expands as
one gets more specific to a particular
subtype let's say estrogen
receptor-positive breast cancer so the
notion and this is one of the ways in
which i think RNAi is being deployed
very powerfully is to try to correlate
the vulnerabilities that are created by
the inactivation of those individual
biological modules and then exploit that
vulnerability for therapy the way that
you can think about this is that cells
are designed or evolved to be robust and
every time you take away one of these
these biological modules these pathways
it affects the robustness of cells think
about a Jenga tower and you're pulling
blocks out of the Jenga tower the more
blocks that you pull out the easier it
is to make that tower fall and what
people are doing with RNAi is is trying
to figure out precisely what additional
block to pull out to make that tower
fall where the tower wouldn't fall if
one had a normal cell which essentially
has homeostatic mechanisms to be robust
to resist the biological difficulties
that would be created by the loss of the
pathway that would represent that key
therapeutic target and so the idea is to
exploit common aspects of the genetics
to create therapies that that overcome
the individuality of the disease
you know it's I came from a very small
town I had very good and very dedicated
science teachers in high school who
really went you know far beyond the call
in a way to make additional science
training available after school hours
etc doing things like science
competitions that we know were held at
local colleges things like this and even
making available some very basic college
science courses during our later years
of high school going on to undergraduate
I went to case western reserve a private
university in Cleveland with the idea
that I was probably going to do medicine
the first semester I was there I needed
a job and talked to my undergraduate
advisor who said hey why don't you come
work in my lab and it took about a week
to decide that you know that's what I
really wanted to do and so you know for
me and I think for many the the turning
point comes as an undergraduate student
when you become exposed to the world of
scientific research it's you know not
something that a lot of people are
intimately familiar with it's not a job
that most people see or encounter and so
I think the key opportunity is to is to
give undergraduates the chance to come
into the lab to provide them you know
exposure to what a life in academic
sciences is really like graduate
education is something that at Cold
Spring Harbor we've spent a lot of time
thinking about and really Jim Watson
pushed very hard about it k to go to
encourage us to fight against the length
of graduate training which was
increasing to what he felt were
ridiculous time frames and so you know a
seven year PhD student essentially not
becoming in Independence
scientists until you know well into
their 30s was something that he thought
completely inappropriate and so we've
really tried to essentially reinvent
graduate education in a way that allows
biologists to get a PhD degree in a
short amount of time four years is our
goal we tend to meet it by and large I
think over the ten years that our
graduate program has been running our
average is about four years and three
months and in fact I graduated a student
yesterday in three and a half years and
so you know the notion of bringing
people into research early and then
giving them an opportunity to do
independent work while they're you know
young and full of fire is I think a
really critical issue that the community
is trying to address
well I mean we work for the public if
you want to think about where the
funding comes for our research it comes
from the National Institutes of Health
which is supported by taxpayers and I
think consequently we have a real
obligation to communicate science to the
public outreach I think should happen at
every level I think that working
scientists should be interfacing with
high schools for example going into to
high school biology class rooms
communicating the excitement of their
work to students cold spring harbor lab
has a has a very strong community
outreach program something they call the
DNA Learning Center and it's designed to
bring middle school students high school
students into laboratories and expose
them to laboratory science I think it's
our obligation as scientists to to reach
out to the public in the form of public
lecture series we also have a strong
public lecture program at the laboratory
I participate in it I know that that
many of the other investigators that the
lab participate in it and I think that
that the public has to understand
science not only because they pay for it
but because science is increasingly a
part of their everyday life and to go
back to the to the the discussion of
sequencing and bioethics a time will
come in the not-too-distant future when
you walk into a doctor's office and they
sequence at least part of your genome
and without a basic understanding of
biology how is the how is the general
public going to react to this how are
they going to understand what's being
communicated to them about their risk of
disease and about how their own genetics
affect their response to treatments
well I mean we work for the public if
you want to think about where the
funding comes for our research it comes
from the National Institutes of Health
which is supported by taxpayers and I
think consequently we have a real
obligation to communicate science to the
public outreach I think should happen at
every level I think that working
scientists should be interfacing with
high schools for example going into to
high school biology class rooms
communicating the excitement of their
work to students cold spring harbor lab
has a has a very strong community
outreach program something they call the
DNA learning center and it's designed to
bring middle school students high school
students into laboratories and expose
them to laboratory science I think it's
our obligation as scientists to to reach
out to the public in the form of public
lecture series we also have a strong
public lecture program at the laboratory
I participated in it I know that that
many of the other investigators that the
lab participate in it and I think that
the the public has to understand science
not only because they pay for it but
because science is increasingly a part
of their everyday life and to go back to
the to the discussion of sequencing and
bioethics a time will come in the
not-too-distant future when you walk
into a doctor's office and they sequence
at least part of your genome and without
a basic understanding of biology how is
the how is the general public going to
react to this how are they going to
understand what's being communicated to
them about their risk of disease and
about how their own genetics affect
their response to treatments
I personally to me what's a
about research is the moment of
discovery I think for most scientists
it's what it Dix you to this the idea
that for just a few minutes you know
something that nobody else in the world
knows and it doesn't happen often
because science is is really sort of an
exercise in banging your head against
the wall over and over again it is
scientists need a very high tolerance
for failure and frustration because most
experiments do fail but when something
really works and you really learn
something fundamentally new it's a
feeling that I think I've never
experienced in any other way